it won't just be fireworks lighting up
the sky this fourth of July lightning
thunder and rain are all expected from
the Gulf Coast to the northern plains
this holiday weekend the rain may bring
some relief from the persistent heat
gripping parts of the nation
meteorologist Jeff Farraday Lee has more
on the nation's weather this weekend and
Jeff we're glad to see you I'm glad to
see you and I'm glad to see all of you
at home good morning everybody so with
this big heat dome across the country as
you can see but it's not going to be a
horrible heatwave yet
two-thirds of the country covered under
kind of a run-of-the-mill heatwave but
each and every day as we go through
Monday into Tuesday and eventually into
Wednesday we're talking about the heat
really building look at Philadelphia
look at Indianapolis look at places like
st. Louis what feels like temperatures
by the beginning of the week in the
upper 90s to near 100 now beyond that
point is when we're really concerned
about the possibility of a severe heat
wave the reason why big Bermuda high
right now located over Bermuda but it's
gonna snake its way south of Florida
kind of retrograding or moving westward
and then it's going to merge with a
ridge of high pressure or dome of high
pressure heat dome if you will across
California this could become a monster
heat wave now it's a little bit early to
know for sure we don't know exactly
where it's gonna set up shop how intense
it's going to be but we could be talking
about feels like temperatures for a
broad area of the plane States at 110
plus as we head towards next weekend and
into the week after we'll have to wait
and see Wow 110 plus all right Jeff
Baird Ellie thank you so much happy
fourth